This phone is never slapped in my pocket obviously.
And the one plus.
Yeah.
You said that that was your favorite phone before the Google Pixel three.
Yup.
And what,
why do you like the Pixel three better than that phone?
Cause I've heard great things about the one plus.
I love the oneplus still and I would have no problem using it today.
But this camera is so much better than every other phone.
Yeah.
Now is that because you take a lot of photos for youtube and blogging and that
kind of thing?
Yeah,
just social.
I tweet a lot of photos at Instagram,
a lot of photos and I just much better.
Yeah,
that's much better.
Then the one plus,
which is already a $600 phone and is the one plus what?
I mean the the galaxy note nine,
it was supposed to have a very good camera as well.
I can't tell the difference.
I'm not good enough.
Most people won't until you put them next to each other and then you kind of go,
oh interesting.
There's a much like when you put an iPhone photo next to a pixel photo,
I phones have notoriously great cameras,
pixels having a choice,
the great cameras,
you might be totally fine with either one,
but if you put them next to each other you will notice massive differences
between the photos.
Yeah.
So did you notice comparisons that are online that we could pull up right now?
Um,
my last one I compare it I a pixel to to iPhone 10 to one plus five t two two
other phones.
I did like a five camera blind test and what I did was I put the five photos
next to each other but didn't tell you which one is which and ABCD or eat and
you go down the list and I have like seven,
eight,
nine photos in a row,
a,
B,
c,
d or e.
Pick your favorite one.
A lot of people went with B.
A lot of people went with D and they didn't know which one.
It was not the end.
I revealed which one was which.
And a lot of people were surprised by which one they picked.
Oh,
I picked the pixel over the iPhone every time.
Really interesting.
Uh,
and a lot of times when you put them side by side,
you'll notice like I iPhones like to boost the shadows a lot more so that
they're much more they lit.
Yeah,
this is that aside.
So like a,
B,
c,
d,
n,
e which one do I like better?
And I already can tell immediately which ones the pixel and you might not
because I wreck,
I remember Pixel two had cooler colors and more contrast in any other one.
And this is a great backpack.
Yeah.
So another thing about these is it helps to see it in a high resolution because
that difference in detail and sharpness between them,
uh,
is another thing I paid attention to.
Which ones he,
I want to say that was the one plus,
but I forget now.
I'm pretty sure be as the pixel cause this great knack pack is starting to look
a little bit blue and that was a big characteristic of the pixel two from last
year.
And that was a big issue with the screen as well.
Right.
The,
to the Pixel.
Xl.
Yeah.
Look at this contrast like you see like all these are like pretty good,
but when you see B and you see how much more contrast that has and you look at a
and how much it's lifted.
The shadows.
Yeah.
He's got,
he's got a pretty even tone and he's also the one plus.
I don't remember what it is.
I'd have to back to the video.
She switched them around with each one every time.
It was the same as the same every time.
Be as the same every time.
I know.
Um,
I don't,
I'm already pretty sure that B is the pixel.
Go to go to the top left one with the selfie.
So again,
like that gray sweatshirt is starting to look at blue and B and e look how much
higher,
brighter.
Those shadows are.
Like my black hair,
it looks kind of gray at that point.
And then that one.
So there's a lot of things you don't notice until you put them side by side.
It's so nitpicky,
they all look so good.
They all look pretty much like the same pair of Syrup.
Yes,
he is a little bit tighter.
So I'm gonna go see as the iPhone because the iPhone has,
has a little bit of a tighter selfie camera.
A lot of android phones have a wider angle selfie camera because you can fit
more people in them.
But Apple's always told me they go with a tighter angle because there's less
distortion and they want it to feel more natural.
You just take a picture of yourself and you look great.
Um,
well here we go.
Iphone x?
No.
Okay.
So you know too in the household I did add a real camera into the,
into the mix.
I'm a real good,
yeah,
I hope so.
It's $10,000.
That was a real camera looked pretty good film or is that,
it's a photo.
So it's a,
it's a medium format.
50 Megapixel Hasselblad,
x one d.
It's a crazy camera.
Your phone actually.
It's pretty God damn good right there.
It does.
But there's just a little bit more to the Pixel to pixel two has,
so this is a portrait mode comparison.
So I remember I was trying to test like the blurry background versus an actual
good camera.
And whenever you look at these portrait mode photos,
what they're doing is they're sort of trying to outline the subject,
keep it sharp and then blur the background artificially and year after year
they've gotten better at this because the fall off between the blur isn't just
like a cutout in real life.
You get sort of like a gradient of how much blur you have.
So Pixel two has typically the sharpest cutout and the best like separation
between the background where the iPhone kind of just takes the face,
keeps the face sharp,
and then sort of has a more natural fall off.
So your body might not be in focus,
uh,
and note eight and it's just not as good.
Yeah.
And that image,
that's a really,
uh,
that in that when you really see how good the pixel to us.
Yeah.
Like that.
And so it takes all three.
Got better at that especially.
Yeah.
So,
and now you can change.
Something.
Note was doing last year.
You can change how blurred the background is on iPhone 10 s now pixel three,
note nine,
all of them.
You can change how blurry the background is.